so you can you cannot just stay with
keep on logs are the other satellite
you have to know key one to the point
where you can start to play with it and
then even go beyond it to where you
start subverting it where where key one
is really you know what we mean when we
say basics is I can take the basics and
I can manipulate them to come up with
something new something different but
but that new is always going to give me
new insights into the building blocks
into the basics to many aikidoka go
around and they just do kihon all
[\h__\h] day she owns everything kyon ki
horn they and they believe that the apex
of the art is getting better a TD me
noggin it's important to get better idea
me not yet for example it's important to
get better at you but that is not the
apex of the heart that is the beginning
level of the art but that's all they do
because when you test for T me not yet
they don't do a test like for the kendo
eight don they put you in two matches
and other masters are watching and
really what they're watching for is that
self detachment because just like when I
watch you and I can tell you're hung up
on this you're hung up on that and
they're doing that to them because that
is the apex of Darth not not not show
McGee not winning the match because your
spirit is your mind is your body mind is
your body heart mind cultivated
according to the ideals of the heart so
that's what they're watching you have
other masters who have achieved that
level they can look at other people and
tell whether they'll have that or not
so you're matching that and that
qualification is really just an
observation for them and and I think
it's even more than that because once
you once your body mind your body heart
mind has achieved that level you don't
really need to see the match I think
they put the match there as a temptation
right the master can look at you as you
get dressed and walk on to the to the to
the arena how you carry your weapon is
it balanced in your hand or are you
dancing with it even as you're holding
it still they can tell but they put the
match there in my opinion the same way
we put keep on there we tempt you we
tempt you with we will your mind clean
here's something nice and shiny and
right and then
sucker always goes for it you want it
you want to you know you want to throw
them so you push on them it's a it's a
it's a trick it's eccentric it's very
much of moving corn master gives you a
riddle and you try to solve it already
so we have to get our kihon down yes but
we can't believe that we've got it down
if all we're doing is key horn problem
we don't really understand Jihan until
it disappears until we can make it
disappear I think then you begin to
understand it and again you know I put
it akin to dancing or learning music
memorizing a song right the master
musician can tell we you just playing
the notes you know what I mean
and they'll tell you hey hey you can
play the notes but you're terrible
you're like what because that's
contradictory to you right and they'll
talk just as abstractly as I do then you
have to feel the music what is this
music make you feel trying to get some
some of the invisible intangible
artistic stuff in there and then you can
play the notes for real when you sit
there you you're playing a four-count
note and you're counting in your head
that note sounds different from they up
from - the musician the master musician
who knows you held that note exactly how
long it needed to be held because you
felt how long it needed to do that
you're not in your head
[Music]
this is very much like this so yep you
got to know your scales but in a certain
point you got to [\h__\h] the scales one of
my first teachers he would always refer
to Picasso so you look at it Picasso
you're like oh my god that stuff is so
weird but he contained the real is the
realism stuff he can do that he did it
so well if we can now play with it
that's why what you trying to draw
crappy because you look at it Picasso
you guys crappy you got I can do crappy
and everyone goes it looks crappy it's
not it's not the same thing so as some
of you've been here a while you you need
to really understand the process okay I
gotta get out of kion to understand kion
and then for you newer people I gotta
get Keeling down down I gotta know where
my foot goes I gotta know the shape of
my hand I got an angle of my arm the
elbow to ribcage relation I got to know
it then I can play with it later
because we don't have we're not burdened
by then I use the phrase burdened by the
delusion of the test all right we don't
we're not going to test and stamp your
passport books and all that crazy crap
we only have it's applicability its
viability so either martially I can do
this or spiritually I can do it that's
all that counts for us and I'll tell you
right now stain stock on kion is not
viable martially or spiritually you can
kick ass all day with your your green
house controlled environment you d be
Nagas you're still going to be an
[\h__\h] you're still going to cause
suffering for you and others around you
you could have a dog and you the
backbone behind your name on our
certificate you're still a [\h__\h] then
you take it out on the street and you're
still gonna get your ass kicked
bathed on and all
but when your Aikido in a way doesn't
even resemble Aikido put to the master
then it's viable viable because if just
go back to that eighth Don kendo test
right the the the the person who's not
an expert but non master will ask the
master why did you give it to that guy
he lost the match shouldn't dr. I be
they thought he won the match he he that
person doesn't understand the Masters
scene what talents what's real and
victory is not real I think about it
you're like what doesn't the best win no
[\h__\h] no not your real violence robot
real violence it's 50/50 every [\h__\h]
time as bet they can be every time you
throw in ambushes you get a person with
a long gun and a scope all you know
you're [\h__\h] dead that's real
so we didn't lose who gives a [\h__\h] but
is your heart mine is that is your
spirit in a weakened state that counts
that counts because that's why I have it
even going back to the map if you if you
go through the matches anybody can lose
one badge if you start doing like 50
matches you'll find more successful with
this awakened spirit that not having it
anyone can lose at any time but overall
same thing in life anyone right under
the right conditions for that day you
ain't just right you slept just right
you can be a nice guy
but what about when you've had a long
work week you didn't get your lunch
your boss yelled at you now you go home
and your kids just want you to [\h__\h]
read that story again you ever see that
movie It's a Wonderful Life
oh you should see it if you haven't
James Stewart
his business is going under everything
is going wrong because homeless kids
family doesn't know it it's Christmas
everybody at homes in the Christmas
spirit and they don't realize we're
broke I'm probably going to jail his
little girl this is so happy that
daddy's home and he loses it that's
happening all over all over to children
all over the world especially in the
modern state
people can't go home be peace in the
waking State is something you can carry
into the thick of battle by which you
mean the ultimate of stress you don't
lose it you might die but you didn't
lose it
I might go to work the next day I might
be [\h__\h] killed tomorrow but I'm not
gonna lose it but I might not make it
home what counts is did he lose it
did he lose it you will not have
understood if you're like I can't
believe you did all that training and he
lost it you're still in fake land of
violence
so the basics yes but also no okay and
that will go also for who can be loaning
in some way when our Naga is no longer
doing t horn UK me cannot consist only
of that great fall forward rolls forward
break fall right so what do I always say
you feel like a cat
you should never fall the same way twice
it should not happen how could it happen
if you can follow the same way twice we
need to hook you up to a computer
innocent because you are an anomaly of
nature that you just repeated time but
how many of you continually tried to
follow the same way every single time
even when it does not match at all what
Naga is doing if you always just fall
the way that your feeling to fall how
can you fall wrong so same thing you're
playing the notes right you're playing
mary had a little hand lamb on the
recorder right only your sit down with
felonious monk and he's like looking in
the [\h__\h] at your gate hey you get what
I'm saying he's improving the [\h__\h] out
of mary had a little lamb and you're
like play something different put that
finger over here don't put it down all
the way while I was thought to put it
down [\h__\h] get out right so you do your
body conditioning you should be strong
you've been taught how to stretch you
should be supple you have your injury
management
you have your body wisdom you're
developing hey punish you some use
stop trying to follow the same way all
the time be dynamic
otherwise it won't end well
someone's playing right jazz improv and
you're playing reporter mary had a
little lamb' from second grade yeah
you're not gonna probably get hurt
okay you have to go with the flow man
okay any questions or comments
observations yes
yeah maybe cuz you do you you help them
with math and I don't help them with
yeah yeah they are you know the kids are
interesting the three of the three ones
they're quite an experiment for me
yeah you know it makes me think about
how you know how many different ways is
this spirit that we're seeking how many
different ways it can manifest itself
and take shape and find uses because
they they don't use it like here I mean
like I don't use it to feel my math
problems or and I don't and I even find
it hard you know - if I get tasked with
something like now to find my spirit
this state in for those kind of things I
have to hate it I have to do the
assessment do you feel your pulse right
are you breathing out all [\h__\h] you're
gonna get back in the right frame here
like you put me in all right
a tactical nightmare everything just
clicks for me and I am I feel much more
at home sad to say you know in those
things those situations and I that I
might you know trying to find the right
driver for a pen tablet which is trying
to be Madison like a great I've seen you
doing a lot order all this one that's
really kick of my eyes
and even like the things they do you
know like do you run with it all of
these days you you haven't had enough
training where you run you run with it
how you run with it
I know yet you have had the experience
of either you have seen how different
prior friends or family trips home have
you come for you from your training it
could be a positive and a negative thing
it could be a positive thing where you
go you know what these people used to
really drive me and I actually ran away
but I found the way back home now
negative thing wow I didn't realize how
toxic my home life was and you know you
don't have to work that out it could
just be a way of relating to relate to
them right and and so you can tell you
can sense your movement when you measure
it against something that did not move
with you and that's one of the ways it
should you do it and so you even though
you might have a problem finding Shiho
nage at the end of this technique or
what have you
right you're still using this in your
various places everyone everyone does
but the point still is always returned
to the mat in the way that zazen is said
to be the center of Zen what it's not
really not not really in any kind of
tangible way you don't spend most your
minutes on the cushion you have special
trainings when you do do that but
normally you don't your time when the
monastery is spent on different things
the majority of your time so same thing
we don't spend that much time on the mat
but we have to be able to return to the
mat to demonstrate that spirit whether
we have it or not whether we can regain
it or not and that's what we mean when
we say the mat is central and we have to
return to the mat so even though you're
using whatever you were able to use off
the mat if you find that you can't use
it on the mat you have a long way to go
whatever you're accomplishing now just
wait okay when you can start turning it
on the mat right and you accomplish the
great things in comparison to now
awesome thank you